The explosion of medical
knowledge and technology
has led to a dramatic
increase in specialization
of medical care,
provider's insights.
One aspect of this is that
care for complex problems
has become increasingly
regionalized.
One downside of
this centralization
is that the relative
ability to properly treat
some classes of patients at
non-centers has declined.
A prime example of
this specialization
is neonatal care.
Newborn medicine has
become highly specialized.
One problem is that many
small hospitals, which
are perfectly well-qualified
to deliver babies,
are not set up to properly
care for seriously ill infants.
This has led to a
dramatic increase
in inter-hospital transport.
Unfortunately, sick babies can
decline astonishingly quickly.
The goal of our system is to
provide continuous real time
medical tele-presence that
will allow experts at the best
neonatal care facilities
to participate
in the care of babies,
both while the baby is
at the hospital in
which it was born
and, should transport
be necessary,
during that critical
period of time when
the baby is between hospitals.
We believe that
deployment of this system
will lead to better patient
outcomes, improved care
while at the community hospital,
improved care during transport,
and better preparation
at the receiving hospital
so that urgent care can
be provided immediately
upon arrival.
Our system has three components,
an instrumented environment
in which the baby can be
cared for and transported,
a communication
subsystem that provides
a bi-directional,
real-time video link
between regional
neonatal care centers,
community hospitals,
and the vehicles used
to transport babies,
and an application that
facilitates collaboration
amongst those in charge
of caring for the infant.
The most technologically
challenging component
of the system to build was
the communication subsystem.
It is built on top of the
commercial cellular data
networks.
Using the cellular data networks
poses a number of challenges.
These networks provide
limited bandwidth,
they suffer from a
high packet loss rate,
and they are
notoriously unstable.
Our solution is to
multiplex the streams
over multiple cellular channels
and exploit carrier diversity.
Here is a video of
one of our test runs.
The first thing we see is
the transport team loading
the isolate into the truck.
Here is a physician from
Children's Hospital sitting
at the application that
runs at the hospital.
There are three cameras, two
focused on the baby and one
on the vital signs monitor.
The doctors can switch back
and forth among these cameras.
There is unfortunately
a slight delay
when the camera is changed to
allow the buffers to refill
so that the video provided
can continue to be smooth.
The doctor is also visible
on the user interface
in the ambulance,
which allows the doctor
to demonstrate procedures that
he or she might wish the team
in the ambulance to follow.
Here's a video from
a different test run.
This baby is approximately
two months old
and considerably larger
than those babies
we expect to be transported.
Notice, however, that
the motion, as perceived
by the doctor, is quite normal
and the resolution perfectly
adequate for
diagnostic purposes.
Frequently, the physicians
will observe something
that they wish to refer
to another physician.
They can save video.
Typically, what
the doctor will do
is want to save video something
he or she has previously seen,
so the doctor is allowed to
save the previous minute or two
minutes or five
minutes of video.
Video is saved on a web server
at the hospital, which can then
be accessed by anyone with
access to the hospital's
network.
It's also possible
to zoom in or out.
Doctors are likely
to do this to inspect
wounds or skin lesions,
perhaps the eyes, things
of that nature.
One of the more popular
features amongst
the doctors is the
ability to take a snapshot
and email that snapshot
to a collaborator
for a second opinion.
In our tests, we
discovered that our system
was considerably more reliable
than cellular telephone
communications.
We also discovered
that the level of noise
in the ambulance, particularly
when the respirator was on,
was sufficiently high that
oral communication could
be a challenge, and the
doctors and the transport team
began to rely increasingly
on the instant messenger
facility for communications.
In conjunction with
our collaborators
at Boston's Children's
Hospital, we
have done several
simulated transport tests.
The physicians found
the system easy to use
and postulated that
it now provides
all the facilities they need to
make an impact on patient care.
Premature births account
for 75% of neonatal deaths
and 50% of
neurological disorders.
Despite these dire
numbers, it is
important to remember that
even for very premature babies,
excellent outcomes are
possible with the proper care.
Our work should help
more babies receive
care that will lead
to excellent outcomes.